[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
en Bourgogne et en franchecté nous
avions prévu de débattre de la campagne
des élections régionales mais il y a une
semaine et quelques heures Paris était
frappé par une vague d'attentat sans
précédent des événements qui se sont
prolongé cette semaine et qui impacte
l'ensemble de la société française de la
vie quotidienne à la vie politique
France 3 a donc décidé dans toute la
France de consacrer cet espace à ce
moment très particulier de la vie de
notre pays bonjour Catherine bonjour
Lilian bonjour à tous je vais donc vous
présenter les quatre invités présents
sur ce plateau nous avons tout d'abord
Éric delzan c'est le préfet de la région
Bourgogne face à lui se trouve Frédéric
paayard secrétaire régional du syndicat
de policier alliance pour la Bourgogne
et la franchecté nous avons également
présent sur ce plateau Thierry Falconnet
maire de chenov Parti socialiste et puis
Alain chrétien député maire de vezou les
républicains nous avions également
invité un représentant de la communauté
musulmane imam est également membre du
Conseil français du culte musulman
malheureusement il n'est pas présent ce
matin et c'est bien dommage vous pouvez
réagir aussi de chez vous grâce au
réseaux social Twitter avec les hashtags
suivants lvl Bourgogne lvel FC lvel BFC
pour Bourgogne Francé vos tweets seront
passés à l' après modération je le
disais le bilan est lourd 130 morts les
objectifs ont marqué les esprits un
stade une salle de concert des terrasses
de café et les conséquences sont
multiples mais avant de les aborder un
mot un sentiment un souvenir même pour
vous quatre on commençant par vous Éric
delzan préfet de Bourgogne à quoi pense
un préfet d'ailleurs comment est-ce
qu'il apprend les événements le préfet
de la région à ce moment-là bonjour
écoutez comme beaucoup d'entre nous je
crois que je l'ai appris par un
SMS immédiatement j'ai j'ai suivi les
informations en direct j'ai surtout
écouté le chef de l'État dans sa
première déclaration nocturne où il a
annoncé qu'il allait décréter l'état
d'urgence et à partir du moment où cette
annonce était faite évidemment j'étais
en première ligne
euh dans le département de cô d'or dont
j'ai la responsabilité en tant que
préfet parce que ça voulait dire que
dans les heures qui allait suivre
j'allais devoir mettre en œuvre les
dispositions de l'état d'urgence on peut
se permettre pardon d'avoir une pensée
personnelle à ce momentlà laassidération
laassidération devant l'ampleur de de ce
qui s'était
passé sans doute parce que aussi comme
tout un chacun je pensais à à des
proches qui était à Paris et puis
surtout je pensais à mon pays je pensais
à mon pays parce
que je voyais bien que nous é rentré
comme le disait le président de la
République en guerre et que il fallait
faire face et que ma
responsabilité comme préfet c'était de
d'être à mon poste pour faire face dans
cet état de guerre que le Président de
la République venait de de constater
fréric paayard vous vous êtes policier
est-ce que quand vous je pense que vous
avez regardé à la télé comme tout le
monde est-ce que vous pensez à vos
collègues ou est-ce que vous pensez à
toute autre chose on pense déjà on pense
déjà au pays en premier lieu puisque les
fonctionnaires de police sont quand même
des serviteurs de l'État donc déjà c'est
déjà le pays avant tout c'est la
sécurité des personnes et des biens qui
nous importent en premier lieu et
ensuite effectivement passer la stupeur
la consternation et puis le le le le
moment de de
d'incrédulité on pense à tous ceux qui
vont intervenir et notamment aux forces
spécial où ces collègues là font
vraiment un travail qui est exceptionnel
et leur professionnalis et vous avez eu
peur pour eux B évidemment qu'on a peur
vous savez on a peur je pense que
maintenant on est dans une situation où
même en tant que représentant du
personnel et représentant syndic on a
peur pour nos collègues tous les jours
tous les jours quand on voit sortir un
véhicule un fourgon police secours sur
une intervention on se dit mais vers
quoi ils vont et qu'est-ce qui peut se
passer il y a rien il y a aucune
intervention banale mais maintenant avec
un million et demi d'intervention par
par an on peut pas dire qu'une
intervention est banale la moindre
intervention peut dégénérer et on a
malheureusement des collègues qui sont
vraiment sous pression au quotidien Tiry
Falconnet on est mer quand on est mer
d'une
commune à quoi on pense alors est-ce
qu'on pense à part aux gens de Paris et
où est-ce qu'on pense très vite à sa
commune et au citoyens de sa commune et
à ce qui risque de se passer dans sa
commune c'est quoi vos premières heures
d'abord comme Monsieur le Préfet j'étais
prévenu par un par un SMS et puis tout
de suite je pense que j'ai fait ce que
bon nombre de concitoyens on fait
c'estàd je me suis mis devant les
chaînes d'information continue et puis
voilà j'étais dans
laassidération je
[Musique]
suivais quasiment j'ai suivi la toute la
soirée euh sur les sur les chaînes de
télévision en voyant le bilan s'alourdir
d'heure en heure et tout de suite très
rapidement effectivement j'ai pensé j'ai
pensé à chenauvre j'ai pensé à ma
commune et puis j'ai alerté j'ai alerté
pardon mes mes plus proches
collaborateurs pour qu'on se retrouve le
lendemain matin euh j'ai suivi également
l'intervention la première intervention
du chef de l'État et je me suis dit
qu'il fallait que le lendemain matin je
sois euh dans mon bureau avec mes
proches collaborateurs pour mettre en en
œuvre les les mesures de sécurisation et
tranquillisation de la population et et
déjà dans la nuit on sursaute au
girophar au bruit bien sûr et puis on on
a les yeux rivés sur le téléphone
portable on attend les réactions les
réactions les éventuels événements de
qui peuvent se dérouler sur le
territoire de la commune alin chrétien
vous êtes bien sûr un citoyen vous avez
deux casquettes politiques maire et
député vous pensez à quoi en
premier beaucoup de tristesse beaucoup
de tristesse ensuite de la colère la
tristesse de voir cette souffrance de
voir ces victimes et ensuite beaucoup de
colère de voir notre pays attaquer comme
l'a dit le chef de l'État c'est une
guerre et ensuite tout de suite on
réagit pour savoir comment tant qu'élu
locale on peut réconforter comment on
peut soutenir nos concitoyens qui sont
parce que en tant que maire vous êtes
tout de suite sollicité bien sûr même
dans une petite ville comme vezou 15000
habitants au contraire dans une petite
ville on fait appel au Mair beaucoup
plus facilement que dans une grande
ville on est très paternaliste les gens
ont besoin d'être rassurés et chez nous
qu'est-ce qui se passe et chez nous
qu'est-ce qui va se passer et puis
ensuite il y a les événements nationaux
siégé au Congrès lundi et puis ensuite
cette loi qui prolonge l'état d'urgence
une ambiance particulière à Paris avec
ce mélange de colère et de tristesse qui
nous envahit parce que nous sommes avant
tout comme vous l'avez dit des citoyens
qui aimont notre pays et qui souffront
avec lui mais quand vous êtes au Congrès
vous avez le sentiment de vivre un
moment historique malheureusement
historque malheureusement historique
malheureusement historique un moment
fort où on s'est tous retrouvé dans
cette enceinte les 1000 parlementaires
sénateurs et députés avec le chef de
l'État avec le gouvernement et là ça
transcende l'éclivage politique ce qui
nous unit est plus fort que ce qui nous
divise même si nous avons encore des
désaccords bien sûr juste une parenthèse
puis on va pas passer le débat là-dessus
mais le mardi il y a une séance plus que
houleuse à l'Assemblée nationale c'était
quoi votre sentiment en tant que député
de l'opposition je vous le dis j'étais
dégoûté j'étais mal à l'aise je suis
parti avant la fin de la séance parce
que cette séance est à oublier cette
séance marquait le niveau de tension qui
existait à Paris qui est un peu le
concentré de latention nationale
d'aujourd'hui le lendemain a été
beaucoup plus apaisé beaucoup plus digne
de ce que doit être un représentant de
la nation de ce que doivent être les
représentants de la nation dans ces
moments aussi difficiles alors on le
disait ces attentats ont bien sûr causé
une véritable déflagration alors une
émotion massive des réactions diverses
on a déjà commencé ce chapitre là en
parlant de et et du lundi et du mardi
euh racontez-nous chacun à votre niveau
les jours qui ont suivi on va dire Éric
delzan alors vous le disiez très vite
état d'urgence donc un certain nombre de
de conséquences euh il y a plein de
choses qui comme un engrenage on va dire
se se mettre en marche à ce moment-là
oui la la première urgence dans ce
cas-là c'est de réunir autour de moi
toutes celles et ceux qui ont un rôle à
jouer encore une fois dans la situation
qui se présentait j'ai réuni dès le
samedi matin l'étatmajor de sécurité
avec les responsables de la police de la
gendarmerie de la justice de l'ensemble
des services qui pouvaient être appelé à
à jouer un rôle ou ou avait une
responsabilité dans un secteur
particulier en particulier le recteur de
l'académie par exemple parce qu'il
fallait tout de suite pouvoir prendre
toutes les dispositions utiles il
fallait par exemple savoir si j'avais à
interdire ou pas euh le weekend dernier
euh il y avait comme vous le savez à
ba des événements très importants
fallait-il que je prenne une décision
d'interdiction j'avais la décision à
prendre entre 9h du matin et 10h du
matin et tous les rassemblements causés
par l'émotion parce que dans beaucoup de
communes bien entendu et bien entendu il
y a beaucoup de questions à ce sujet là
bien entendu et c'était pas facile de
dire par exemple je vous demande de ne
pas vous rassembler de manière impromptu
parce que des rassemblements nécessitent
d'être sécurisés et que je mobilise
toutes les forces de sécurité de police
et de gendarmerie sur des missions qui
sont prioritaires et c'est pas une
décision facile parce que les gens
avaient besoin d'exprimer leur émotion
mais j'observe que le lundi ça a été
aussi très fort et dans toutes les
villes de la région dans toutes les les
cheflieux où beaucoup beaucoup
d'habitants de cette région Bourgogne de
cette région franchecé se sont réunis il
y a eu des milliers d'habitants qui sont
sortis de chez eux qui ont respecté une
minute de silence qui ont chanté la
Marseillaise ensemble et ça c'était un
moment très fort il y a eu un autre
moment très fort pardon je terminerai
là-dessus le mardi nous avons été réunis
tous les préfets de France au
ministerère de l'intérieur et ce qui est
quasiment sans précédent le président de
la République est venu lui-même nous
parler et il nous a mobilisé et je crois
que nous sommes repartis de là tous les
préfets avec notre feuille de route pour
encore une fois la
sécurité des Françaises et des Français
alors nous avons deux maires sur ce
plateau ils ont pris des décisions
diamétralement opposées contenu donc des
circonstances vous Thierry Falconnet
vous avez vous avez annulé un spectacle
qui devait avoir lieu et vous Alain
Joyandet vous maintenez la fête al
chrétien pardon vous maintenez la fête
de la Sainte Catherine mercredi à
vezoule alors pourquoi vous avez pris la
décision d'annuler votre spectacle
écoutez tout d'abord c'est une décision
qui n'est pas facile à prendre
c'est-à-dire
que
j'ai comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure réuni un certain nombre de
collaborateurs des élus autour de de moi
pour prendre la température hein de de
de l'état d'esprit ensuite nousous
sommes rendus sur le terrain
c'est-à-dire que euh nous avons circulé
dans les installations sportives dans
les installations culturelles qui
étaient ouverte samedi matin et nous
étions en contact avec la population et
vraiment nous avons ressenti à ce
moment-là euh toute la toute la
tristesse toute la sidération toute tout
le le désespoir de nos de de nos
concitoyens et
puis ce deuil qui qui était qui était
présent le deuil national été décrété
par par le chef de l'État et il est vrai
que après avoir pris l'avis de de de la
préfecture à ce sujet je je remercie
vraiment le préfet et ses services pour
la disponibilité dont il ils ont su
faire preuve à ce moment-là vous répondz
à la question qu'on allait vous poser
est-ce que dans ce cas-là on a un
rapport avec le préfet oui euh tout de
suite au téléphone j'ai eu sa directrice
de cabinet qui effectivement à qui j'ai
fait part de de mes réflexion et et et à
qui j'ai j'ai dit que je je souhaitais
que le deuil à chenauve soit strictement
respecté je sais que il y a eu des
réactions mais c'est pas c'est pas par
peur que vous avez annulé non non non
non c'était vraiment par dignité et par
dessence pour les 130 victimes et les
300 blessés de des attentats de Paris
alors ça venait très vite effectivement
on va dire la dimension temporelle est
différente pour vous pour un événement
qui vient un peu plus tard c'est
mercredi 25 novemb de très un événement
de très grande ampleur en même temps
c'est 20000 personnes dans les rues
c'est ça l'année dernière après Charlie
j'avais devais faire mes vœux pour le
nouvel an je les ai effectivement annulé
c'était le lendemain on peut pas se
réunir de manière festive quand on vit
des moments comme cuxla la se caerine
comme vous le l'évoquez c'est le 25
novembre prochain 25000 personnes une
tradition qui a presque 500 ans j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi depuis ces événements
tragiques de vendredi j'ai finalement
pris la décision de maintenir cette
cette fête avec comme vous l'avez dit un
lien étroit avec la préfecture avec les
services de police nous n'avons pas
voulu montrer notre peur même si chacun
est inquiet est-ce que vous avez peur
quand même on a tous peur aujourd'hui on
a tous peur bien malin celui qui peut
vous dire aujourd'hui je suis serein il
Meque il ne m'arrivera rien dans le
métro à Paris à Chenau à Dijon à ou
partout on a on est légitime à avoir
cette peur donc j'ai beaucoup travaillé
avec les services de la préfecture nous
aurons un service
d'encadrement assez spécifique on va
dire renforcé pour cette journée
spéciale ça veut dire combien d'hommes
mobilisés je vous voulez pas les
chiffres disons que la Sainte Catherine
sera encad encadrée sera renforcé une
coopération exceptionnelle entre la
gendarmerie la police nationale la
police municipale l'ensemble des
services qui concourt à la sûreté des
Français au quotidien et là aussi je
salue l'efficacité avec laquelle tous
ces services sont mis en œuvre les eff
souci s'il y a un souci c'est vous Alain
chrétien bien sûr qui êtes responsable
bien sûr je je l'assume mais les maires
le savent nous sommes en première ligne
sur tous ces sujets-l et j'ai pris cette
décision en mon âme et conscience en
ayant toutes les garanties que nous
puissions passer une journée en toute
sécurité et en toute sérénité mais après
personne n'est à l'abri faut-il que la
France s'arrête parce que certains
teristes veulent lui faire peur faut-il
qu'on renonce à nos traditions à nos
valeurs à ce qui nous est cher parce que
certains veulent nous anéantir et bien
non il faut que nous nous soyons tous
debout face à ces menaces nonobstant le
fait qu'elles sont réelles et qu'on doit
en prendre conscience on parlait de
sécurité justement Frédéric Payard vous
étiez sur ce même plateau il y a
quelques semaines on parlait de ce que
les syndicats de police demandaient
comme moyen supplémentaire c'était avant
que François Hollande n'annonce déjà
précédemment des moyens supplémentaires
pour la police vous nous disiez déjà on
s'en souvient c'est le moment où un
certain nombre de CRS avaient fait euh
sinon grève du moins geste de mauvaise
humeur avec était tous mis en arrêt
maladie voilà c'est ça euh et et là ça
veut dire quand même que ce qui se passe
vient sur un terreau dans lequel les
forces de sécurité en France sont à 100
% déjà depuis des mois et des mois
est-ce que c'est faisable de votre point
de vue ou en tout cas est-ce que c'est
une inquiétude qui qui traverse les
syndicats ben je pense qu'on va arriver
au bout d'un exercice qui c'est déjà
assez compliqué périeux puisque on avait
dans les services on commençait on va
dire très officiellement à se remettre
de l'après Charlie les collègues ont
commencé à reprendre une vie un peu
normale dans les services en ayant à
l'idée qu'éventuellement il y avait
toujours la menace puisque la menace
après Charli elle a été identifiée elle
ne devaut pas s'arrêter comme ça ça
c'est c'est une évidence c'est c'est
faire preuve de pragmatisme et de et de
réalisme de de de réagir comme ça mais
derrière il est vrai qu'on a des
collègues là qui qui ont une AMP des
amplitudes de services qui sont assez
importantes on a des contraintes de
service et chaque événement qui n'est
pas prévu ou prévisible amène des
modifications dans le fonctionnement de
la police et dans la vie quotidienne de
nos collègues donc on voudrait vraiment
que les choses soient faites et qu'il
soi vraiment pris en compte cette
spécificité et que les moyens qui sont
promis arrivent rapidement un mot sur la
spécificité de ces attentats pour la
première fois en France il y a eu alors
le mot est peut-être pas approprié mais
des cicases ça veut dire non pas des
gens que vous pouvez arrêter en tant que
force de sécurité mais est-ce que ça
veut dire que dans la tête des la police
la gendarmerie des forces spéciales on
instaure un nouveau rapport une nouvelle
dimension et donc de nouvelles façons
d'agir ça devient beaucoup plus
compliqué d'intervenir et d'agir puisque
là ça on est vraiment sur quelque chose
qui peut être sournoix et qui est
totalement imprévisible et qui peut
frapper n'importe où et sur tout
intervention de ce type-là maintenant le
risque d'avoir quelqu'un avec une
ceinture d'explosif ou d'avoir euh
quelqu'un qui a piéger un appartement ou
quelque chose est de plus en plus
important donc les moyens d'intervention
et les méthodes d'intervention forcément
ne seront pas les même alors quand vous
dites manque de moyens d'effectif et
cetera ça veut dire que déjà les gens
qui sont sur le terrain sont épuisés
donc ils sont peut-être plus en mesure
d'assumer correctement leur mission ben
on peut être inquiet sur sur la santé et
sur la sécurité des collègues mais on a
des collègues qui sont très
professionnels et qui font vraiment leur
travail avec abnéation quand on a des
gens qui sont qui sont capable de
travailler 21 heur d'affilé sur certains
services ça démontre quand même
l'engagement de nos collègues et ça
démontre l'engagement des des forces de
police de gendarmerie et des militaires
sur un sujet qui est vraiment sensible
pour garantir la sécurité au cotidien
Éric delzan quand on déclenche tout ce
que vous avez dû déclencher au soir des
attentats on sait aussi que les forces
de sécurité sont déjà dans un flux
extrêmement
tendu c'est possible de le prendre en
compte ou finalement il est pas question
de le prendre en compte à ce moment-là
évidemment qu'il faut le prendre en
compte et je voudrais à cette occasion
rendre hommage au travail et à la
mobilisation de ces forces de police et
de gendarmerie mais aussi des des
militaires et de l'ensemble de ceux qui
concourent à la sécurité de nos
concitoyens je voudrais dire que par
rapport au au aux deux réactions qui ont
été celles des maires que vous avez
interrogé je crois qu'elles étaient
toutes les deux très
bonnes celle de
l'immédiateté de respecter le deuil et
puis celle de dire il faut que la vie de
ce pays continue il faut que ce qui
fait la la la force même de notre pays
ses valeurs sa culture continue il faut
pas donner la
satisfaction de de nous arrêter de vivre
et c'est très important que cette fête
de la Sainte Catherine ait lieu et je
sais parce que j'en ai parlé avec ma
collègue de la h zone que ça nécessite
des moyens effectivement importants je
rappelle à cet égard que tout ne peut
pas reposer sur le rôle de la police et
de la gendarmerie il faut que les
organisateurs de ces manifestations
prennent leur respons abilité pour
assurer un certain nombre de de mesures
hier soir par exemple je me suis rendu
dans des lieux à Dijon pour vérifier que
les condition de sécurité d'accès à des
lieux publics le stade le Zénit était
bien était bien respecté mais j'ai
constaté aussi que et bien la population
était au rendez-vous de ces ces
événements et c'est très important att
je je vous interrompes parce que là
quand vous dites donc les organisateurs
on voit par exemple que le maire de can
a monté des espèces de milices parce que
je trouve pas d'autres mots de citoyens
vigilant est-ce que c'est à ça que vous
appelez ou pas je peux pas du tout
commenter ce que fait le maire de Cann
je peux vous dire ce que moi je demande
hier soir j'ai réuni 500and vous
demandez l'intervention des citoyens ça
veut dire quoi concrètement je vais vous
dire hier soir j'ai réuni les maires de
la Côte d'Or ils étaient 500 à être
présents c'est tout à fait exceptionnel
ce que je leur ai dit c'est qu'ils ont
évidemment un rôle primordial à jouer à
cet égard dans le cadre des
responsabilités des missions qui sont
les leurs et avec pour beaucoup d'entre
eux notamment dans les v les plus
importantes des polices municipales et
vous savez que le Président de la
République a dit que l'État apporterait
un effort
supplémentaire envers les polices
municipal notamment pour leur armement
si c'était demandé par le de leur part
mais il y a aussi un rôle évidemment des
citoyens et je le dis aussi les
organisateurs de manifestation ont un
rôle à jouer mais il faut qu'il le
fassent dans le casadre des lois de la
République je crois que c'est très
important aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
l'état d'urgence mais nous sommes aussi
dans l'État de droit et les deux doivent
se combiner et je crois que tous les
débats qui ont eu lieu au au Parlement
cette semaine ont bien montré cette
double exigence de faire face à
l'urgence avec l'état d'urgence et en
même temps de respecter l'État de droit
et c'est ce qui est notre force dans ce
pays je pense autre question pour les
maire on le redit on avait invité un
représentant de la communauté musulmane
et on aurait aimé lui poser un certain
nombre de questions mais on peut les
poser aussi au maire qui dans les jours
suivants je suppose et vous y répondrez
aussi mais en commençant par Thierry
Falconnet est-ce que que la communauté
musulmane de votre commune vous avez eu
des contacts avec eux quel était leur
sentiment est-ce que la population dans
tout le pays était inquiète mais est-ce
que la communauté musulmane elle elle
était inquiète aussi et et selon quel
sur quel motif al d'abord je voudrais
juste faire une petite précision
sémantique à laquelle je tiens la
communauté musulmane je ne sais pas ce
que c'est je connais la communauté des
citoyens français à égalité de droit et
de
devoir je connais des concitoyens de
confessions musulmanes je préfère
employer cette cette terminologie
utiliseer celle que vous souhaitez euh
j'ai été en rapport immédiat avec avec
nos concitoyens de confession
musulmane
qui qui étaient eux aussi en
colère en colère parce que tout de suite
c'est ça a été de dire pour eux nous
allons encore porter le chapeau nous
allons encore devoir nous justifier
alors que nous ne nous ne sommes
absolument pas seul solidaire de de ces
barbares et de ces terroristes et et
donc il m'a semblé
important même si je suis un maire
laïque de m'adresser à nos concitoyens
de confession musulmane par un message
que je j'ai adressé à l'imam de la
mosquée de chenauve pour leur dire tout
notre soutien et que nous ne faisons pas
d'amalgame ils sont à part entière des
citoyens français à égalité de droit et
de devoir est-ce que vous avez éé
beaucoup de musulmans dans les
rassemblements et dans les minutes de
silence parce que c'est peut-être le
moyen le moment pour eux justement en
participant à ces mouvements de
solidarité de de faire en sorte que
l'amalgame ne soit pas fait j'ai réuni
près de près de 500 personnes pour la
minute de silence à Chenau lundi sur le
parvis de l'Hôtel de Ville ensuite nous
avons tenu un conseil municipal
extraordinaire qui a aussi rassembler un
nombre conséquent de nos concitoyens il
y avait toutes les catégories de
population était représenté des jeunes
des moins jeunes de toutes origines de
tous les quartiers voilà cette cet
esprit d'unité nationale qui est porté
par le chef de l'État aujourd'hui les
maires portent cette unité de leur ville
dans leur ville et c'est très important
pour nous chrétien ça s'est passé
comment c'est chez vous vous savez ça
fait très longtemps à vezou quelques
années maintenant que on travaille sur
la citoyenneté qu'est-ce que la
citoyenneté qu'est-ce que ça signifie
d'appartenir à une nation de partager
ses valeurs donc moi je n'ai aucune
étude chez les vésuliens sur ce sujet
parce que peu à peu on les sent
sensibilisés on les sent avertis sur ce
sujet quelques soient leurs origines et
moi je serais tenté de dire que tout le
monde est le bienvenu en France à partir
du moment où il exprime son amour pour
le pays qu' l'accueille et c'est sur ces
sujets-là qu'on va nous attendre dans
les mois et les années qui viennent
parce qu'il y a les mesures d'urgence
comme on l'a tous dit euh qu'est-ce
qu'on fait dans les jours qui suivent et
ensuite comment on se remet en cause
dans notre action sur le long terme
quelle pédagogie on fait
comment se fait-il qu'aujourd'hui un
gamin de 15 ans puisse crier vive daesh
comment se fait-il qu'aujourd'hui des
des enfants respectent pas la minute de
silence il faut qu'on se remette en
cause par rapport à ces comportements là
pourquoi on est-on arrivé là c'est ça la
vraie question et comment faire pour que
ces jeunes comprennent qu'aujourd'hui il
ne respectent pas les valeurs d'un pays
qui les a accueillis c'est la vraie
question quelle que soit l'origine parce
que vous avez des petits français bien
français qui ont la le même comportement
et on le voit avec tous ces convertis
nés en France d'origine française ça
crée un vrai sentiment de malaise par
rapport à la défense de nos valeurs vous
savez il y a quelques années certains
voulaient changer les paroles de la
Marseillaise parce qu'il la trouvait
béliqueuse relisez-les les paroles de la
Marseillaise aujourd'hui elles sont
d'une cruelle actualité d'une très
cruelle actualité il a un couplet il un
couplet numéro 11 qui est différent des
autres moins béliqueux que les autres
malgré tout malgré tout vous en tant que
maire quel est le pouvoir que vous avez
par exemple sur une mosquée puisque à la
mosquée de vezou sont passés plusieurs
jeunes francontois qu'on a retrouvé
après en Syrie vous quel est vot votre
pouvoir très limité aujourd'hui ce
pouvoir de vous dites limité parce que
vous voulez pas dire aucun pouvoir non
le seul pouvoir qu'on a c'est le pouvoir
de cohésion pouvoir de dialogue le
pouvoir de mettre les gens les relations
en relation les uns avec les autres mais
le pouvoir de de répression de suivi de
signalement appartient à l'État avec des
services hyper compétents la DGSI les
services territoriaux bref l'état
connaît son territoire nous en tant
qu'acteurs locaux on a bien sûr le pouir
de police police municipale d'interdire
des certains un rassemblement de
réglementer la voie publique notre
travail c'est surtout un travail de
coopération entre les gens de tisser des
liens entre les gens de tisser des pont
entre les communautés qui ne se
parleraient plus et c'est un travail
quotidien faut aller dans les quartiers
en civil entre guillemets sans la
cravate et le costume pour parler avec
les gens ça c'est notre vrai pouvoir le
pouvoir juridique le pouvoir militaire
le pouvoir de sécurité il est très
limité pour un maire il appartient à
l'État et on est là pour soutenir l'État
dans ce travail fondamental de sécurité
et de surveillance du territoire qui est
essentiel thry Falconnet vous vouliez
répondre non c'est pas une réponse c'est
peut-être un un complément un complément
moi je vous avez fait référence tout à
l'heure au aux attentats du mois de
janvier oui j'ai eu dans la population
de Chenau et notamment dans la jeunesse
des réactions assez assez forte à ce
moment-là des mois de janvier des des
des gens qui ne se reconnaissaient pas
nécessairement dans le slogan je suis
Charlie dans la
mobilisation aujourd'hui après ces
attentats les choses ont changé
c'est-à-dire que le caractère aveugle
les balles ne sont pas racistes elles
n'ont pas été racistes vendredi soir
elles ont touché tout le monde les je
pense au au aux deux
creusotines voilà d'origine d'origine
étrangère qui ont été qui ont été qui
ont été tués P ces attentats
c'est-à-dire que il y a une véritable
prise de conscience aujourd'hui que ces
attentat pe tou ce que vous êtes en
train de dire ce que vous êtes en train
de dire c'est que que ce soit Mohamed
Mera ou que ce soit à Paris au mois de
janvier on a tué des militaires des
policiers des Juifs des journalistes
quelque part il l'avait
chch ce n'est pas ce que c'est ça he
c'est ça vous êtes en train de dire que
la réaction est différente parce que
cette fois-ci la victime est universelle
alors que avance dans la communauté
musulmane même si vous n'avez pas ce
mot-l en fait certains étaient je suis
Charlie mais quelque part ils l'ont bien
cherché de manière très minoritaire de
manière très
minoritaire et là je ne l'ai pas
ressenti dans dans la commune dont j'ai
la responsabilité euh on va avancer sur
ce débat on a parlé de la semaine qui a
suivi hein euh et puis maintenant euh on
on va entrer dans le long terme euh
puisque en fait ces attentats posent un
certain nombre de questions d'évolution
de notre société en commençant par notre
vie quotidienne Éric delzan est-ce que
vous votre sentiment ou en tout cas le
message puisqu'on sait que les préfère
rencontrer le président de la République
on rencontré les maires aussi ont
rencontré le président de la République
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux
est-ce que ça veut dire que notre vie
quotidienne va changer est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'on vivait sans se rendre
compte de ce qui pouvait nous arriver
qu'à partir de maintenant plein de
choses seront différentes alors d'abord
il s'est passé un certain nombre de
choses cette semaine qui justement
tirait leur source dans les décisions
qui ont été prises au plus haut niveau
de de
l'État l'état d'urgence c'est pas juste
un mot c'est un certain nombre de
réalité qui m'ont permis en tant que
préfet comme à tous mes collègues des
départements des des deux régions euh de
prendre un certain nombre de mesures
fortes euh et nous allons d'ailleurs
poursuivre dans cette voie renouvelée et
amplifiée puisque le Parlement a
définitivement voté hier et la loi a été
promulguée ce matin sur l'état d'urgence
et donc par exemple dans les h
départements de cette des deux régions
cette semaine il y a eu une cinquantaine
de perquisitions
administratives décidé par les préfets
et qui ont permis euh de de de traiter
un certain nombre de de
situations pourquoi pourquoi maintenant
50 pourquoi pas dans les mois précédents
puisque là d'abord dans les mois
précédents l'état d'urgence était pas
déclaré et il pouvait pas y avoir de
perquisition administrative c'est déjà
une bonne aur pu elles auraient pu se
faire sur un autre motif juridique on va
dire il auraient pu se faire habituel
vous savez on fait pas de perquisition
en temps normal autrement que par la
voie judiciaire hein donc l'état
d'urgence c'est aussi une réponse de de
de d'immédiateté par rapport à une
situation particulière hein qui est
celle de de ce que notre pays vit depuis
une semaine donc je crois qu'il faut que
chacun sache que la réponse elle est
apportée elle ne se borne pas à cela
évidemment mais elle est apportée et
elle permet de vérifier ce qui se passe
de mettre à l'écart éventuellement
euh des personnes qui présentent une
dangerosité particulière de saisir des
armes euh voilà c'est ça la réaction
immédiate qui est prise et je peux vous
assurer qu'elle ne s'arrête pas mais
dans un cadre juridique encore une fois
qui est celui de l'État de droit
oui monsieur Paillard par rapport
justement à ces mesures et cetera ça
veut dire quoi concrètement pour vous et
pour votre relation à la population
concrètement ça veut dire qu'on a une
modification quand même des des des
méthodes de travail le le la situation
d'état d'urgence B conduit aux
perquisitions administratives comme l'a
dit Monsieur le Préfet
permettent quelques contrôles ça une
lisibilité à 3 mois puisque l'état
d'urgence c'est promulgué jusqu'à la fin
du mois de février mais il faudra
qu'après les choses évoluent également
pour que euh les policiers puissent
travailler et continuer à faire leur
travail on va dire de façon de façon
logique suite à ces événements
c'est-à-dire que comme le dit Monsieur
le Préfet l'État de droit doit reprendre
ses droits mais éventuellement on pense
qu'il faudrait que certaines choses
évoluent notamment en matière de lutte
contre le terrorisme et que les lois et
les les articles du Code pénal qui sont
qui sont dédiés à cette situation là
puissent évoluer dans un sens favorable
pour permettre ça c'est le député à la
chrétien qui va nous répondre tout à
l'heure mais par exemple le fait que les
policiers même hors service aent le
droit de garder leur armes qu'est-ce que
ça change pour vous est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est une bonne mesure ou pas
au moins jusqu'à la fin de l'état
d'urgence déjà ça va déjà
amener du monde du monde en armes sur le
terrain puisque on a quand même vu que
vendredi
soir le le le le fait subi par le fait
subi par le pays était quand même
relativement violent que la violence
peut s'installer partout on l'a vu
autour du stade de France on a vu tout
ça ce qui était terrible c'est qu'à
l'intérieur du Bataclan il y avait un
couple de policiers qui était là mais
qui n'avait pas leur armes bah allez je
pense fautarde quand même un petit peu
une faut quand même qu'on garde une
proportion
[Musique]
entre faut être pragmatique on va pas un
concert de rock avec une avec une arme
je pense que quand même quelque part à
un moment faut faut peut-être qu'on ait
quand même je je ve pas dire
l'intelligence mais je pense qu' faut
que ça soit fait quand même dans le bon
sens dans le bon sens c'est au quotidien
dans les déplacements des policiers déjà
on avait la possibilité l'arme était
déjà conservée sur le temps de transport
pour se rendre au travail mais après on
peut imaginer qu'un policier qui fait
ses courses un samedi après-midi ou qui
est en mission de liaison pour pour une
pour un motif personnel s'il est armé et
qu'il constate un fait de toute façon le
policier est policier 24h sur 24 ça je
pense que quelque part on est on est
dans dans dans la règle et euh un des
outils et un des des des matériels mis à
disposition des policiers pour pour
arrêter les forfaits c'est l'arme de
service donc avoir son arme de service
au quotidien sur la base du volontariat
et dans des conditions encadré ne peut
qu'améliorer la sécurité alors puisqu'on
parle d'armes avant de parler loi et
évolution des lois puisqu'on a un
législateur mais on a deux élus un mot
quand même on sait que le Président de
la République mercredi devant 2500 ma a
annoncé que l'État était prêt à aider
toutes les communes qu'il souhaitaent à
armer leur police municipale euh pour
pour ceux qu' le souhaitent euh il y a
eu des réactions très diverses des gens
qui s'étaient déjà lancés dedans et qui
souhaitaient continuer des gens qui
n'ont pas voulu euh quelles sont vos
réactions aux uns et aux autres quelle
est la situation chez vous Alain
chrétien qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé
de ça et puis euh Thierry Falconet va
nous dire aussi il n'y a pas une police
municipale il y a des polices
municipales avec des contextes très
différents entre entre les villes et
entre les communes la ville de Nice par
exemple a une police municipale énorme
avec beaucoup beaucoup d'équipement
alors que dans nos petites villes
moyennes vous savez moi j'ai neuf
policiers municipaux ça veut dire que
j'en ai quatre ou cinq sur le terrain
donc il faut doubler l'effectif pour
avoir un effectif à peu près correct
dans une ville de 15000 15 17000
habitants je ne suis pas pour l'armement
général des polices municipales je suis
pour qu'on puisse donner aux policiers
municipaux des moyens supplémentaire en
terme de contrôle d'identité il faut que
le policier municipal puisse demander
l'identité à un citoyen dans la rue
alors ça pose des problèmes juridiques
puisque il faut avoir les pouvoirs de
police judiciaire il y a une réforme à
faire plus de pouvoir juridique pour les
policiers municipaux ça il faut que tout
le monde en soit doté par contre
l'armement des polices municipales doit
être fait en fonction du contexte
municipal et de la volonté de la commune
mais surtout pas armer toutes les
polices municipales Thierry Falconnet
moi je n'y suis pas favorable vous avez
posé la question à vos à vos policiers
je n'y suis pas favorable d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de de de collègues de
l'agglomération ont se sont exprimés
François
rezamen le maire de Longvie le maire de
kétini donc moi je n'y suis pas
favorable j'ai interrogé les policiers
municipaux à ce sujet je voudrais saluer
leur mobilisation exemplaire C ces
derniers temps parce que ce weekend par
exemple je les ai je leur ai demandé de
de suspendre leur congés ils étaient
présents sur le terrain ils ont été en
contact avec la population vraiment ils
ont fait un travail remarquable je n'y
suis pas favorable par parce que ils
mèneent une d'abord une mission de
police de proximité voilà donc ils sont
au contact ils sont au contact parfois
de manière un peu rugueuse avec avec la
population et ils font leur travail dans
des conditions qui sont difficiles je
rappelle chenauve
quartier prioritaire politique de la
ville c'est pas simple de voilà d'être
policier municipal dans dans une commune
comme comme la mienne ils font leur
travail avec beaucoup de
professionnalisme en revanche que nous
nous préoccupions de leur de leur
sécurité à eux c'est-à-dire qu'ils
sortent avec les gilets par bal qu'ils
sortent avec une GoPro hein avec une une
caméra lorsqu'ils ont des interventions
sur la voie publique il y a aussi la
coordination avec la police nationale
chose auxquell nous nous tenons et
auquell nous travaillons quotidiennement
il y a aussi tous les dispositifs de de
vidéo protection qui existent et qui
peuvent qui peuvent être aussi utilisés
donc je pense que nous nous disposons
déjà les maires d'un certain nombre de
de de possibilités en le domaine je
pense que l'armement n'est pas
aujourd'hui l'actualité qui dit armement
de la de la police municipale dit
évolution législative dit formation des
policiers municipaux et surtout
changement de nature de leur de leur
mission quotidienne est-ce que d'avoir
une arme ça les mettrait encore plus en
danger pas forcément tout le temps quand
même oui oui non mais pas forcément tout
le temps mais je je pense que ça n'est
pas la ça n'est pas la solution c'est
pas la leur mission c'est pas comme ça
que vous envisagez leur mission à moins
que l'État ne décide de d'une évolution
sensible des choses je pense que ce ce
n'est pas aujourd'hui la mission de la
police la police municipale er delzan ça
fait partie des choses qu'il faut
prendre en compte aussi il y a la police
nationale il y a ce que les communes
sont capables de faire avec leurs
policiers mais aussi des polices
municipales qui sont différentes d'une
commune à l'autre et ça vous devez en
tenir compte moi je crois que ce qui est
important et Monsieur le Maire de Chau
va parler de coordination moi je
parlerai aussi de complémentarité il
faut qu'il y ait une réelle
complémentarité entre ce que fait l'état
avec ses forces que ce soit la police
nationale la gendarmerie nationale et
puis ce que font les communes avec leur
police municipale et Monsieur le Maire
de vezul a tout à fait raison on peut
pas du tout être dans la même situation
quand on a une police municipale avec
une dizaine de de de personnels et quand
on en a une avec 100 50 c'est pas du
tout la même nature mais l'important je
crois c'est que ces polices ont chacune
leur rôle hein ont chacune leur
responsabilité l'important c'est de les
faire travailler en complémentarité
c'est de pas être dans la confusion et
je crois que les citoyens sont très
attachés à bien voir le travail des unes
et des autres vous savez ce que je
constate aujourd'hui c'est que dans le
cadre des conseils locaux de prévention
de la délinquence par exemple on a
considérablement fait converger hein la
manière dont police nationale quand on
est en zone police et police municipale
travail ça c'est tout à fait essentiel
c'était la revendication de beaucoup de
maires mercredi à Paris ces conseils
locaux de prévention de la délinquence
en demandant à ce qu'il soit plus
efficace et que il y ait un partage
d'information beaucoup plus grand à
l'intérieur c'est une piste oui bien
entendu vous voyez par exemple avec
l'accord du du président du du Grand
Dijon nous allons créer une instance
intercommunale de prévention de la
délinquence qui va concerner les
principales communes de l'agglomération
digunaise pourquoi pas pour créer une
super police d'agglomération pas du tout
mais pour faire de la coordination
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui dans une
agglomération comme celle de Dijon c'est
la structuration urbaine avec le tramoou
qui a changé la donne et aujourd'hui il
faut faire travailler ensemble il y a
une zone police une zone gendarmerie il
faut faire bien travailler ensemble la
police et la gendarmerie il faut faire
bien travailler ensemble police
municipale police nationale voilà je
crois que c'est ça qui attendent nos
concitoyens c'est de voir que tous les
acteurs de la sécurité travaillent
ensemble encore une fois pour la
sécurité collective vous comprenez le
sentiment des maires en général qui ont
l'impression d'avoir beaucoup de
responsabilités sur leurs épaules et
relativement peu d'informations qui leur
viennent justement de l'État et des
préfectures écoutez je peux tout à fait
entendre ce que vous dites hier soir
quand je me suis adressé à 500 m de la
Côte
d'Or j'ai pas eu le sentiment qu'il
manquait
d'information je crois effectivement
qu'il y a beaucoup d'information parfois
il faut surtout trouver le moyen de la
donner de la meilleure manière possible
je crois que c'est effectivement un
souci permanent qui est le mien et moi
j'ai dit à tous les maires de ce
département je pense que mes collègues
on font autant dès que vous avez une
question que vous vous posez
appelez-moi pour me pour me dire voilà
il y a telle situation Monsieur le
Préfet qu'est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut qu'on fasse il y a telle
manifestation qui se tient comment
est-ce que je dois faire on est là pour
je moi j'ai une fonction de de conseil
hein et puis vous savez on est souvent
plus intelligent à plusieurs Frédéric
paayer un mot quand même sur l'armement
des polices municipales quelle est la
position de votre syndicat là-dessus
est-ce que c'est une bonne idée on se
rappelle quand même que dans les
événements de janvier des policiers
municipaux ont été pris pour cible
immédiatement et ils n'étaient pas armé
euh ben ça fait partie ça fait partie si
vous voulez de nos revendications
puisque Monsieur le Préfet a employé des
mots pour qualifier les partenariat nous
au niveau d'alliance police nationale on
appelle à une coproduction de la
sécurité et c'est des mots qui sont
forts quand même puisque quand on dit
coproduction c'est qu'on veut que tous
les acteurs qui sont chargés de la
sécurité soient dotés des moyens qui
permettent de garantir la sécurité et
qu'on ait une une interconnexion entre
tous que ce qui est fait par les uns
soit utile aux autres et vice-versa ça
c'est quelque chose qui doit qui doit
être qui doit être la règle ensuite
après les textes de toute façon je pense
que vu la situation du pays actuellement
les choses vont évoluer très logiquement
il y a des il y a des choses qui vont
bouger l'armement des policiers
municipaux fait partie sur la base du
volontariat et comme les maires l'ont
rappelé comme Monsieur le Préfet l'a
rappelé également font partie de d'une
possibilité cette possibilité si les
personnels qui sont dans ces polices
municipales sont en demande si les
effectifs sont suffisants et s'il y a
une réelle nécessité dans le type de
mission qui leur sont confié je pense
qu'on ne peut pas négliger ce fait là et
les policiers municipaux doivent être
armés et dotés des matériels et matériel
qui permett d'accomplir leur mission
alors il nous faut parler de loi aussi
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure on se
souvient qu'il y a quelques semaines
allz un peu plus quelques mois une
partie de la classe politique s'est
écharpé sur la loi renseignement qui que
beaucoup jugeaient liberticide et puis
finalement l'état d'urgence est prolongé
3 mois chrétien bouge la tête en disant
c'est pas vrai ah quand même un petit
peu l'état d'urgence est prolongé de 3
mois on parle même d'un changement
constitutionnel sans que finalement
personne n'y trou prouve à redire à peu
près dans la classe politique vous allez
nous le dire mais la gauche d'abord
parce que c'est une partie de la gauche
qui avait pu s'opposer à la loi
renseignement Thierry
Falcon il y aura un après 13 novembre
2015 voilà je pense
que la gauche le Parti socialiste dont
je suis membre doivent prendre toute la
mesure de ce qui s'est passé vendredi
soir elle le prend je crois que le chef
de l'État je vous interromps par exemple
la prolongation pour pour l'état
d'urgence six députés de la majorité
trois écologistes trois socialistes dont
Barbara Romagnan député socialiste de la
première circonscription du dou ont voté
contreoui OUI et euh il faudrait faire
la soustraction et et les autres ont
soutenu ont soutenu l'état d'urgence je
pense qu'il y a il y a une réaction
quasi
unanime de la majorité pour soutenir le
chef de l'État le chef de l'État
aujourd'hui est le garant de la sécurité
publique euh de nos concitoyens il est
aussi le garant de la politique
étrangère qui est qui est mené
actuellement et dont on dont on note des
inflexions très sensibles je pense que
c'est une position de de responsabilité
moi je soutiens et nous soutenons le
chef de l'État et puis surtout nous
avons besoin d'unité et de cohésion
nationale derrière le chef de l'État
pour que nous
réglions cette cette question du
terrorisme du terrorisme vous avez
prononcé le mot tournant c'est vraiment
ça au sein de votre parti mais au sein
de la gauche aussi est-ce que c'est sous
la pression de la population d'une
certaine manière ou c'est sous la
pression le mot est peut-être fort mais
sous l'émotion générale aussi que un
certain nombre de d'élus s'aperçoivent
que on va dire le logiciel ancien n'est
peut-être plus adapté aujourd'hui ça
fait un moment quand même que la gauche
a a pris conscience d'un d'un d'un
certain nombre de de de réalité en mat
de ses maires beaucoup oui de des élus
locaux et et puis aussi euh aussi de de
de de de la population je je crois que
nous avons rompu avec un certain
angélisme et nous sommes dans une dans
une position de de responsabilité par
rapport aux questions de sécurité
publique bien entendu nous sommes
foncièrement attachés aux libertés
individuelles mais aujourd'hui force de
constater que après le 13 novembre nous
devons prendre des des mesures peut-être
temporaires je l'espère de de de
restrictions des libertés individuelles
si vous me posez la question est-ce
qu'il faut choisir entre la sécurité et
des libertés pleines et entières je dis
aujourd'hui nous choisissons la sécurité
al juste un mot donc un sondage donc qui
est sorti cette semaine 84 % des
Français sont pour davantage de contrôle
si ça leur apporte une meilleure
sécurité 84 % de la population Alain
chrétien vous êtes à l'Assemblée vous
votez les lois vous aussi
euh on le disait il y a eu quelques voix
discordantes mais globalement c'est une
unanimité dans les deux chambres encore
plus fortte au Sénat d'ailleurs sur ce
qui est proposé pour l'instant vous
partagez cette position il y a un avant
et a un après y compris dans dans les
textes et dans ce qui va régir notre vie
en société vous savez la semaine qu'on a
vécu est une semaine historique comme on
l'a dit euh qui nécessite que la France
soit unie derrière l'exécutif moi je
suis dans cette position mais le temps
du débat
reviendra le temps des contradictions
reviendra on l'a dit nous demandions
cette inflexion que le président a
évoqué dans son discours du Congrès
depuis longtemps une inflexion en
politique étrangère qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec Bachar elAssad une inflexion en
politique sécuritaire avec cette fameuse
déchéance de nationalité que la gauche
ne voulait pas entendre parler dont elle
ne voulait pas entendre parler il y a
quelques mois et qui maintenant est à
l'ordre du jour des inflexions qui sont
bonnes parce que nous les demandions pas
de polémique nous sommes dans un temps
d'action nous devons vont soutenir
l'état soutenir les forces de police
dans un temps de protection mais la
démocratie do doit jouer son rôle pardon
et nous devrons un jour demander des
comptes au gouvernement sur le temps qui
a été perdu pour prendre ces décisions
qui sont indispensables vous parliez de
modification législative j'étais en
commission des lois mercredi soir pour
l'examen de cette loi qui prolonge
l'état d'urgence pour 3 mois et j'ai
proposé que nous puissions que les
services de police puissent saisir les
ordinateurs et les téléphones portables
lors des perquisitions administrative
car pour l'instant ça n'est pas possible
il faut judiciariser il faut donc
trouver une infraction donc maintenant
c'est possible non justement je l'ai
redemander en séance publique de
l'Assemblée nationale jeudi matin devant
le Premier ministre on m'a opposé à un
refus alors que c'est indispensable que
vous vous imaginez que les policiers
rentrent dans un domicile ils trouvent
un ordinateur ils n'ont pas le droit
d'exploiter l'ordinateur s'il est éteint
s'il a un mot de passe ou s'il est
endommagé il faut que ce soit le
procureur qui trouve une infraction pour
pouvoir emmener le ordinateur afin de de
d'extraire les données dans un
laboratoire moi je demande qu'on puisse
le faire sans l'autorisation du
procureur donc vous voyez qu'il y a
encore beaucoup de travail à faire sur
ces modifications législatives afin
qu'on puisse donner au servic de police
des vrais pouvoirs concrets
d'investigation mais ça doit se faire
maintenant pas dans 3 mois donc réviser
la Constitution peut-être on verra bien
on sait pas ce qu'il y a dans cette
révision de la Constitution aujourd'hui
l'urgence c'est donner maintenant au
servicees de police les moyens d'inves
révision de constitution puis que donc
entre l'article 16 et l'article 36
c'estàdire le pouvoir au Président de la
République ou le pouvoir à l'armée pour
faire simple on voit bien que c'est plus
du tout adapté à la situation vous allez
quand même avoir 3 mois pour en discuter
là il va y avoir un vrai débat et et
vous pensez que donc cette unité
nationale va voler en éclat et que
chacun va reprendre ses positions je
pense pas qu'elle va voler en éclat on
est dans une démocratie et chacun va
apporter ses idées chacun va apporter
ses arguments pour faire la meilleure
loi possible pour les Français quand une
loi est bonne moi je la vote la loi sur
le renseignement je n'ai eu aucun État
d'â à la voter même si elle été défendue
par jean-v ledriillant et Emmanuel Vals
je l'ai voté des deux mains parce que
c'est une bonne loi même si elle vient
d'un gouvernement que je ne soutiens pas
c'est ça la différence unité nationale
ne veut pas dire uniformité nationale on
a le droit de pas être d'accord sur tout
à partir du moment où on apporte les
bons arguments qui arrivent à convaincre
l'autre parti de l'Assemblée nationale
c'est ça la vraie démocratie alors
l'autre parti voulait répondre même si
n'est pas l'Assemblée nationale pour oui
non simpleement la loi sur le
renseignement est une bonne chose voilà
nous avons besoin l'État a besoin
aujourd'hui de muscler son dispositif en
matière de renseignement intérieur et
puis donc monsieur chrétien soutiendra
également la proposition du chef de
l'État de rétablir des effectifs de
police qui manque qui manque cruellement
sur le terrain et je pense que ça n'est
pas le syndicaliste policier qui me
démentira je rappelle 13000
fonctionnaires de police ont été
supprimés le chef de l'État a annoncé le
recrutement de 9000 fonctionnaires
supplémentaires ce qui reviendrait à
rétablir le niveau des fonctionnaires de
police au niveau avant 2007 et je trouve
que c'est une excellente chose
effectivement la justice la police a
besoin de moyens encore faut-il qu'il y
ait suffisamment de fonctionnaires pour
pouvoir remplir ses missions un un mot
sur jusqu'où on va les Américains ont
vécu quelque chose d'assez équivalent
enfin d'assez équivalent on pourra
peut-être comparer c'est le 11 septembre
on se rappelle que il y a eu par la
suite le patriote acte qui a eu un
certain nombre de choses aux États-Unis
certes les deux régimes sont pas
comparables néanmoins on est allé très
loin dans ce pays ça a été Guantanamo ça
a été on le sait aujourd'hui on est allé
jusqu'à torturer des
gens c'est difficile de vivre ces
moments-là pour l'État aussi parce que
la question c'est la limite haute Éric
delzin on perquisitionne mais jusqu'où
on va qu'est-ce qu'on fait et quelles
sont les bordures les bordures c'est
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure euh la
Constitution euh l'État de droit mais
cela permet quand même un élargissement
assez important des capacités d'action
la loi que le Parlement vient de voter
par exemple permet que le cadre
juridique des perquisitions
administratives soit étendu et Monsieur
le Député sans aller jusqu'à sans doute
la demande que vous aviez faite
j'observe que un des articles de la loi
élargit la possibilité d'accéder à des
informations stockées sur des matériel
informatiques alors je crois que c'est
déjà une réponse importante parce
qu'effectivement on avait ce on avait ce
ce cette contrainte là non je pense que
après il m'appartient pas de prononcer
sur l'ampleur des autres réformes qui
ont été annoncées je constate simplement
qu'avec la loi qui a été promulgué ce
matin les conditions dans lesquelles
l'état d'urgence s'applique et les
pouvoirs qui sont donnés à l'autorité
administrative et je rappelle que ce
sont des pouvoirs graves hein parce que
ce sont des pouvoirs qui habituellement
ne lui sont pas conférés et que euh
quand on est en responsabilité euh dans
ce type de situation qui touche aux
liberté individuelle comme l'a rappelé
tout à l'heure Monsieur le Maire il faut
le faire évidemment en respectant
scrupuleusement les règles mais
j'observe que les pouvoirs qui me sont
désormais donnés euh vont me permettre
effectivement je pense de traiter encore
mieux euh les les les les situations
préoccupantes avec cette difficulté que
sous le coup de la colère je pense à la
population beaucoup de gens me le disent
il y a la colère mais il faut faire
attention euh de de pas aller trop loin
ça concerne tout le monde Frédéric paard
y compris les forces de l'ordre parce
que l'émotion elle peut être très forte
à certains moments il faut tout le monde
doit réussir à garder son sang froid et
ça c'est une question qu'on peut poser
finalement à tout le monde mais en
commençant par vous bien sûr garder la
tête froide dans telle situation je
pense que c'est la règle et puis c'est
ça qui va garantir que on puisse vivre
vraiment pleinement sécurité donc c'est
sécurité mais pas tout sécuritaire c'est
ça si on résume je pense qu'il faut
quand même trouver le juste milieu et
puis il faut quand même que malgré tout
on oublie on n'oublie pas qu'on est
quand même dans un pays de liberté et
que ces libertés ben les les services de
l'État on sont les garants et on ne doit
pas sous prétexte de réaction
émotionnelle cautionner n'importe quoi
Alain chrétien quand la population est
inquiète quand la population demande les
élus doivent
aussi tenir on ne gouverne jamais sous
la colère il faut toujours du recul il
faut de la distanciation par rapport à
tous ces événements moi je comprends la
colère des fr français je comprends leur
sentiment de révolte par rapport à cette
violence et je la partage simplement
quand on est responsable politique on
doit prendre ce recul nécessaire pour
prendre les bonnes décisions au bon
moment interdire ou pas une
manifestation prendre une décision de
restriction des libertés tout ça sont
des choses extrêmement lourdes qui
nécessitent pas de la froideur mais un
peu de distance par rapport à
l'actualité parce que nous sommes comme
vous l'avez dit les garants des libertés
publiques et on ne doit jamais agir sous
le coup de la colère c'est ça en
démocratie qui est indispensable ti il
falconnaet c'est la même chose parce que
l'émotion elle peut être forte dans une
commune oui euh elle est forte dans une
commune mais elle est forte sur
l'ensemble du territoire national juste
peut-être une remarque qu'on cherchait à
à à faire les terroristes vendredi soir
ils ont cherché à abattre euh ce qui
fait euh la France c'est-à-dire une
terre de liberté la patrie des Droits de
l'Homme chercher à diviser la population
à à nous euh amener dans la dans la
terreur et dans l'effroid et et la la
France est un grand pays elle doit
réagir à la hauteur de de cette vision
universelle qui a toujours été celle de
la nation française et en ce sens je
pense que il faut que nous ayons nous
trouvions des mesures
proportionnées par rapport à cette
demande légitime de sécurité de nos
concitoyens et le maintien de ce qui
fait la beauté la grandeur de notre pays
alors on va en parler après les
informations midi on parlera aussi de
ces phénomènes de radicalisation que
parfois les maires sont amené à à voir
sans forcément parfois vous nous le
direz peut-être savoir vraiment comment
intervenir et puis on parlera aussi de
ce qu' a changé des des symboles
peut-être la Marseillaise des choses
qu'on qu'on a vu ressurgir on se
retrouve juste après les informations de
midi à tout de suite